all right so this wins the Internet
today I guess when I upload this video
it'll technically be tomorrow not
tomorrow is when you're watching this
it'll be tomorrow which would be day
after tomorrow at the time I'm saying
this but I'm saying tomorrow in terms of
tomorrow per the time I'm actually
saying when tomorrow is gonna be which
is today what do some good stuff happen
for some Star Wars fans today so I'm
pretty happy about that is totally we're
talking about the bringing the Clone
Wars back I talk about this because even
though I have not done a video or review
of the Clone Wars animation I have seen
it well I've seen most of it actually I
found this cheat sheet that was like
okay here are all the Clone Wars
episodes that are enjoyable and
important and you can skip the others so
I just watched what was on this cheat
sheet skip the episodic stuff which
means I love 100 percent of what I've
seen in the Clone Wars
that's not lazy it's just a smart way to
go about life but sadly the Clone Wars
animation was just cancelled it wasn't
canceled as in oh you're cancelled so
now please wrap it up and they wrapped
it up it just ended I mean we know where
it ends up obviously so you can argue
that it does have a conclusion in
Revenge of the Sith but the path to
getting there definitely has a large gap
so now they're doing a final season I
think that's great when I see trailers
like this I try to put myself in the
perspective of an audience member who's
seeing it for the first time it's by the
time I see it online I know what it's
titled I know what it's all about if I
was there in the audience and I heard as
Commander Cody and I see a helmet I'd be
like the one who says a war left
unfinished until now you're like oh my
god they're bringing it back there's
actually a video of someone who had a
camera in the audience while this
trailers playing and at that moment the
crowd just goes bananas I'm happy the
crowd gets to go bananas I'm happy
people get a conclusion for the clone
war there are a few things worse than
when a show you genuinely enjoy that
doesn't deserve to get cancelled gets
canceled I'm gonna pause here for a few
seconds take it in still hurts so now it
gets a conclusion the big reveal in the
trailer is Anakin comes to this room
he's like alright Rex what's so
important you had us brought all the way
back here you see the hologram of a
selca she's a little older she's like
hello master it's been a while I mean
she was a fan favorite I thought a suck
it was great and the Clone Wars
animation really did do its job in me
believing in Anakin had an apprentice
out there and the Clone Wars animation
also had to make Anakin's abrupt leap
into the dark side believable for the
fans they shouldn't have had to do that
the movie should have taken care of that
but since the movies didn't the
animation did it'll have to definitely
at least touch on what happened to Darth
Maul right is when we left him in Clone
Wars he didn't actually have an end
to his ark and he showed up in rebels
you know like what were you doing and
you only dabble we got was recently we
found out I guess he's dabbling in the
criminal underworld I guess how did he
get there I imagine this will show how
we got that so right there I wonder how
much of this new season of Clone Wars
exists for the sake of tying Clone Wars
into new Star Wars stuff like how much
of its gonna tie into rebel is how much
is gonna time to sell though how much
gonna tie in it for whatever whereas
before I felt like it existed to you
know show us what happened in the Clone
Wars but also make Anakin's turn more
believable so I hope they keep their eye
on that prize and don't make us some big
cross-promotional thing we're Disney's
like alright everything's linked to
everything I just want to keep it here
just link into the movie the catch is
the fact that Clone Wars is going to
stream on Disney's streaming service
that they're coming out with which when
I heard about it everyone heard about
it's like I have enough streaming
services like this he's like yeah we
totally get it so what will get people
to download this well they're really
clamoring for a final season of Clone
Wars well you make that happen there
might have been a statement out there
but nothing in this trailer at least
says it's going to be one season it
could be a couple here's a twist a plot
twist or at least a twist in execution I
figure the Clone Wars animation will
lead up to Anakin and obi-wan like we
have to go to Khorasan because the
Chancellor has been kidnapped then it
leads into the beginning of Revenge of
the Sith logical right but what if what
if that's the second to the last episode
and the last episode concentrates on all
the soldiers and one soldiers like hold
on general Jedi person I have a phone
call execute oh the 66 this more murder
and mayhem maybe some Jedi generals are
trying to escape and they get hunted
down shot I'd like to see more order 66
hunting fallout and murder this is me
that's a pretty good reveal a bootleg
version you hearing the crowd go nuts
you just I'm glad fans get this sweet
hell I'm interested in also cheap as
hell so I guess I'll wait to watch it
but all I'm saying is now we know for a
fact it is possible to bring voice
actors back to reprise their roles for
their characters for a show that's been
cancelled if all you needs the voices is
it really impossible can we just have an
animation we can keep it going still
alert so Star Wars Clone Wars it's
coming back are you glad to hear the
news what do you think about it whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]